in Death Valley normally one of the
driest places on Earth flood waters
cascaded over a highway one sign of
tropical storm Hillary's Force as it
battered Southern California the storm
made landfall on Mexico's Baja
California Peninsula on Sunday and moved
swiftly northward one person was
reported killed in Mexico when their
vehicle was Swept Away 26 million people
are in the storm's path the National
Weather Service warned of catastrophic
and life-threatening flash floods
particularly affecting low-lying desert
areas some towns were under evacuation
orders elsewhere people loaded up on
sandbags and sought shelter indoors
we're batting down the hatches in Los
Angeles Heavy Rain flooded intersections
public schools in LA and San Diego will
be closed on Monday one person was
rescued from the rain swollen LA River
right now it is critical that angelinos
stays safe and stay home unless directed
otherwise by safety officials record
rainfall hit Palm Springs and
neighboring towns as if the storm wasn't
enough a 5.1 magnitude earthquake hit
Sunday afternoon near Santa Barbara and
was felt by people throughout the area
as Darkness Falls millions of people
throughout this region are waiting
anxiously for the full force of tropical
storm Hillary to descend as one senior
official in San Diego County warned the
worst is yet to come
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Palm Springs
California